what's up everyone it's your local Giga
Chad back here with his new fresh
fade haircut because every single time I
get a haircut or decide to style myself
I want to look like one of my Jewish
icons so basically this time I went from
sandbagm and freed over to Drake anyways
as you can see I'm feeling sexy and I'm
ready to talk about databases so let's
get into it alrighty so in our last
video we talked about different types of
SQL databases what I really mean is
relational databases but this is the
term that everyone uses so it is the
term that I will use in order to stay
consistent So today we're going to
introduce another term which I've talked
about in this channel in the past but
not in this series and that is going to
be new sequel so whereas our traditional
SQL databases are things like my Sequel
and postgres SQL new SQL databases have
kind of arisen during the era of nosql
databases but they've kept that
relational mentality and the reason
they've done this is because they offer
some type of extra twist to the typical
SQL database that makes them worth
discussing so today obviously based on
the title little video we're going to be
talking about volt DB and then I'll
probably do spanner which is Google's
version of a new SQL database in maybe
the next video
so the question really boils down to
this how do we speed up transactions
well if you remember from last video I
basically insinuated that MySQL does
two-phase locking where every single row
has a lock that can be grabbed in either
shared or exclusive mode
shared mode is for reading transactions
or read-only transactions exclusive mode
are for transactions that include rights
similarly postgres has serializable
snapshot isolation where you read from a
consistent snapshot the database keeps
track of the other transactions that are
also basically using that piece of data
in order to fulfill their own needs and
then if one of them commits you might
have to roll back one of those
transactions of course these are
somewhat slow and obviously they're kind
of the main bottleneck to getting better
performance within a single database
node so whole DB has actually come
around and tried something new which is
the following actual serial execution so
as opposed to you know using locking
trying to do multi-threading or anything
like that it has just gone ahead and
literally created a queue of things to
do these are our operations and they're
literally going through one single CPU
thread so the problem here obviously is
that if we've only got one single CPU
thread then the bottleneck of our system
is actually going to be the CPU
and it means that as a result of that we
need to be able to finish every single
operation as quickly as humanly possible
and so how can we actually go ahead and
do that well first we need to evaluate
what our bottlenecks are other than the
CPU of course because we want to be able
to make all of those operations on the
CPU as fast as possible so hopefully two
main ones should stick out to you guys
the first being this guy right here what
is this obviously it is our hard drive
hard drives are pretty slow to write to
simply just because they're not really
part of your computer they're kind of an
add-on and it's also just a metallic
disc that literally spins around and we
have to jump around this chode thingy
and basically find where our data is
that we want and then the second one is
going to be Network latency right if I
am someone who's writing to the database
and I want to do that multiple separate
times all within the same transaction
that is going to seriously bog us down
it would be a lot better if we can keep
every single operation or every single
transaction to One Singular interaction
with the database over the network we'll
talk about how we can do that later in
the video
so how do we deal with disk in terms of
speeding things up such that we can
improve our performance and avoid the
overhead associated with disk operations
well Vault DB said screw disks we're
putting every single thing in memory
it's effectively like a cache or a redis
instance really but as opposed to just
being a typical key value store it's
still a relational SQL type database so
what is the pro of doing something like
this well the biggest one that should
Stand Out is that now we have hash
indexes we can basically keep all of our
data in a hash map and that means that
we now have o of one reads and writes of
course it's worth noting that you know
just by nature of having a hash map you
keep all of your stuff in different
places on memory and as a result if you
wanted to run a range query that would
be tough for that instead you could do
an optional tree set index or a sorted
set and that would make your operations
of log n
of course as well you might be thinking
well shoot if all of our operations are
going into memory how are they going to
be durable how can we actually ensure
that if our databases to go down these
things aren't going to break well we do
have the option for a right ahead log
however of course if that log is going
to be on disk that is going to slow us
down too hence why it's optional
so what's the main con of having
everything in memory well of course
memory is expensive and what that means
is that now you cannot have as much of
it on a single node and of course that
means that if you want to have the same
size data set you need more partitions
now we've spoken about why having a ton
of partitions with a SQL database in a
distributed setting can be pretty
inconvenient it means that for a lot of
your reads and writes you're probably
going to have to be reading from and
writing to multiple places especially if
you need your data to be consistent and
accurate All rights that go to multiple
partitions are going to require
distributed transactions and thusly
two-phase commit which we know is really
slow because it requires multiple round
trips to every single database because
of course we need to basically propose
get a response
and then after that we can finally
commit so that's three trips between the
two databases so obviously two-phase
commit is really going to slow things
down we want to be running that as
infrequently as possible and if we're
constantly doing cross partition rights
that is going to be a problem
of course if you do use Vault DB the aim
should be to be doing as little of that
as humanly possible
so how can we also deal with network
latency because we mentioned that this
is a bit of a problem as well well let's
first present on the left over here the
bad case let's say we as as opposed to
the client maybe this should be better
if I represented it as the application
server
but either way the point is we're
telling the database to do something
the database responds with some value
and as a result we reach back out to the
database asking it for some other query
at the same time what we could do
instead is in advance
we could send all of that logic
to the database
you know we have our entire script here
with the conditional if else oops sorry
I got my Eraser out
we have our if else right here and as a
result now all we have to do is actually
induce the script on our database as
opposed to doing multiple round trips
and that right there is known as using a
stored procedure now stored procedures
are kind of looked down upon I think
these days simply just because you know
it's kind of hard to manage that code
it's not really treated as you know full
application code but when you are kind
of strapped your time on each operation
you do basically have to make some
sacrifices and using stored procedures
in this case is going to be one of them
so what's our conclusion well volt DB
within an actual systems design
interview probably isn't something that
you're ever going to bring up most
likely just because your interviewer
isn't going to know about it and you're
going to sound like you're a crazy
person if you start talking about it
however it is very important as a case
study in terms of other ways that you
can achieve isolated transactions
achieving acid transaction is basically
the main bottleneck to any database that
is attempting to use them and so as a
result of that this approach of
literally running every single thing on
a single thread is very interesting of
course it makes us have to give up
certain functionality in order to be
able to do it and there are a lot of
concessions that we need to be to be
able to make but nonetheless it is worth
talking about anyways guys have a good
week and I'm looking forward to making
the video about spanner